[Musica]
[Applauso]
beh
a questo punto avrei davvero bisogno di
un invocazione a musa è che mi guidi e
mi aiuti in questo ragionamento intorno
al concetto di bellezza
da filosofo sono sempre in imbarazzo a
parlare di bellezze anche da filosofo
che si occupa da tanti anni di estetica
perché magari voi vi aspettate che forte
di una lunga tradizione occidentale che
ha sempre considerato il bello magari in
unione col buono col giusto possa darvi
delle risposte o perlomeno dei
suggerimenti utili per dipanare questo
mistero del bello
mi dispiace deludervi per me rimane
ancora un grosso punto interrogativo
però il bello e le muse hanno un
elemento in comune questo elemento in
comune è l'elemento mitico sono due miti
in pratica se dovessi riassumere quella
che oggi è la posizione della filosofia
rispetto al bello è che nessuno ci può
credere sul serio è una specie di favola
però però è una favola che al fondo
conserva una verità o cela una verità e
dunque seppure gli studi di estetica
hanno abbandonato il tema del bello da
ormai quasi 100 anni
le persone nelle loro pratiche
quotidiane non lo fanno e direi che è da
questo sfondo problematico che possiamo
cominciare a porci la domanda su che
cosa sia il bello
innanzitutto
potremmo dire che il bello non è una
cosa non è individuabile come una cosa
bella ma anche se noi ci spingessimo a
cercare definire il bello come una
proprietà delle cose ci troveremo ben
presto in imbarazzo in effetti se ci
pensate possano essere belli i fiori le
albe bambini i cuccioli ma anche le
combinazioni degli scacchi i teoremi
delle matematiche le buone intenzioni
quindi diciamo che è difficile definire
una classe omogenea di oggetti di cui
predichiamo che se uno che sono belli
omero esiodo fisiche hanno inventato le
muse
pensavano che bello potesse essere
un'azione nobile è buona ma anche una
morte gloriosa in battaglia poteva
essere poteva essere bella è anche
ricordare o cominciare a pensare che il
bello in pratica è
una con qualcosa di storico c'è un
qualcosa che nasce all'interno di una
determinata cultura e condivide i valori
e il sistema di giudizio direi che non
ci aiuta in effetti
questo fa sì che il bello condivida il
destino delle culture in cui nasce cioè
muore e nasce con con loro e
se invece appartenersi alle cose come
una specie di proprietà a chimica
dovrebbe essere in qualche modo
connaturato alle alle cose mentre invece
sappiamo che cose che solo pochi anni fa
ritenevamo essere molto bella adesso non
lo sono
non lo sono più e
allora potremo provare intanto a fare
una prima grande distinzione fra un
bello naturale che noi troviamo appunto
nella natura è un bel loro artificiale
cioè il bello che dell'apd quello che
che viene creato dall'uomo da allora
nel bello dell'arte non c'entriamo
nemmeno un po perché anche l'arte ha
abbandonato da un bel po
il
problema del bello all l'obiettivo di
fare arte bella ma d'altra parte anche
il bello naturale
cc pone un sacco di interrogativi e un
sacco di domande
prima momenti no a pensarci
questa rosa è bella ma perché per
esempio non è bella
una lucertola o un verme
anche rispetto al corpo umano
abbiamo un sacco di criteri estetici per
definire belli gli occhi il viso di una
persona ma accogliendo quella che era
una provocazione di david cronenberg il
grande il grande regista
perché non esistono concorsi di bellezza
per organi interni che ne so lorraine e
più bello il fegato più bello e quindi
laddove appunto ormai la conclusione la
confusione sembra regnare sovrana ecco
che forse però possiamo
intuire un filo che se seguiamo potrebbe
forse aiutarci a uscire da questo
vespaio questo filo lo
scopre alla fine del settecento un
filosofo tedesco che si chiamava
immanuel kant ecco la sua idea è che
il bello non vada cercato tanto degli
oggetti ma più sull'altro lato ovvero
sul lato di chi di chi li guarda ti chi
guarda chi guarda le cose e quindi prima
di cercare di capire che cos'è il bello
devo un po cercare di capire come
funziona questo strano animale che è che
è l'uomo è infatti canta ferma il bello
è un tipo di giudizio non appartiene
agli oggetti vuoi quelli naturali o vuoi
quelli artificiali
appartiene alla capacità di affermazione
di chi giudica
e
quando io dico una rosa è bella dico
qualcosa di molto diverso che se dicessi
una rosa e rossa perché nel secondo caso
io definisco e discrimino nel primo caso
invece io mi riferisco soltanto ai
sentimenti di piacere o dispiacere che
ogni cosa qualsiasi cosa che ho incontro
la mia vita provocano su di me quindi
bella non è la cosa bella è bello è il
sentimento che provo è che posso appunto
giudicare come com'è bello il bello non
è neanche il piacevole come posso dire
che ne so a me piace il gelato al
pistacchio
e c'è di più dice kant quando io dico un
tramonto è bello può una rosa è bella
lui dice
pretendo all'universalità cioè sono
dell'idea che tutte le persone in quel
momento debbano condividere il mio il
mio giudizio
io posso benissimo ammettere che ci
siano persone che preferiscono il gelato
al cioccolato o anche di quelli che
amano la vaniglia ma in verità di fronte
al giudizio è bello io pretendo
all'universalità cioè
riconosco negli altri la mia stessa
identica capacità di giudizio c'è
un'espressione molto bella di cannes che
alghe maine steam cioè c'è una voce
comune il bello parla con una voce
comune una voce che appartiene a tutti è
il fondamento di una prima di una prima
comunità beh è già una prima svolta è
già una prima volta forse che ci sia
qualcosa di possibilmente
universale nel giudizio del bello forse
che possiamo trovare qualcosa che è
valido in qualsiasi epoca in qualsiasi
località storica in qualsiasi cultura
moderni studi recentissimi studi di
neuroscienze vanno proprio questa
direzione cioè pensano proprio che che
possa che possa essere così
recentemente sono stati pubblicati
proprio degli studi cross culturali che
quindi sono stati fatti in varie parti
del mondo in varie
categorie sociali delle parti del mondo
e anche in varie fasce di età
e per definire se esiste un calo tipo
della bellezza e in effetti hanno
scoperto l'esistenza di un calo tipo
della bellezza del volto femminile al
quale tutti i maschi adulti
eterosessuali
reagiscono allo stesso modo lo stesso
vale per i corpi sia a quelli maschili
sia quelli femminili la le proporzioni e
l'asimmetria come già sospettavano i
greci sono proprio elementi costitutivi
della bellezza in modo transculturale e
trans individuale
certo il fatto che la bellezza abbia dei
fondamenti universali non significa che
la cultura non influisca profondamente e
in maniera spesso radicale e ancora di
più l'esperienza personale
dell'individuo non influisca in maniera
assolutamente radicale su quella che poi
è il l'idea di bellezza che ciascuno di
noi di noi sa ma significa
una una cosa più più sottile ovvero
che al fondo di tutte queste diverse
idea di bellezza agisce un meccanismo
più più più profondo addirittura hanno
scoperto che abbiamo un calo tipo innato
e universale per quanto riguarda la
bellezza del paesaggio come hanno fatto
a scoprirlo hanno mostrato foto di
paesaggi terrestri diversi a
moltissimi bambini da tutto il mondo e
le preferenze di tutti i bambini si sono
orientate verso il paesaggio della
savana
poi ovviamente
quando le persone crescono invecchiano
diventano molto più sensibili alla
bellezza dell'ambiente nel quale sono
sono inserite ora per cercare di capire
perché questo elemento di universalità
rispetto al bello
vi conduca in una specie di esperimento
mentale che è stato proposto da un neuro
scienziato indiano si chiama annunciata
e che riguarda queste strane costruzioni
sono in inglese kudos in italiano camini
delle fate ma non ho mai sentito prima
sono delle costruzioni come vedete di
roccia nelle quali un
cappello di roccia più dura ha protetto
gli estratti inferiori che sono di
roccia più friabile calcarea che quindi
si sarebbero sciolti con gli agenti
hanno seri allora lui ci invita a
immaginare un tempo molto lontano in cui
tutti questi kudos erano vivi
camminavano sulla terra e si
innamoravano fra di loro ad alcuni dos
piacevano judo schael cappello adage
piacevano quelli senza cappello altri
judo skurhavy altri gli woods dritti e
ciascuno a secondo quello che era il
proprio talento chiamiamolo così e col
passare del tempo però le intemperie
hanno risparmiato solo gli kudos che
sono coperti da un pesante solido
cappello di roccia che li che li
proteggesse e cosa vuol dire vuol dire
che
in verità i
caratteri universali del bello che noi
abbiamo non sono in realtà innati o
presenti fin dall'inizio ma sono il
risultato di un processo quindi quello
che è avvenuto per gli usa o qualcosa di
simile è avvenuto anche per gli animali
e che per gli e per gli uomini
i criteri e gli elementi del bello che
sono presenti oggi sono quelli che sono
sopravvissuti
diciamo così alla selezione naturale e
quindi non sono lì fin dall'inizio ma
sono proprio il risultato di un processo
non è che la simmetria e la proporzione
corrispondono al tipo di bellezza
originaria ma sono quelli che alla fine
sono stati piu utili all'uomo e più
efficaci per la nostra sopravvivenza in
questo in questo ambiente dunque si
potrebbe dire che la bellezza è una
forza che guida le nostre scelte ed è un
bene che lo faccia come sanno benissimo
da anni i responsabili del marketing o
delle campagne elettorali e arrivando
all'ultima parte di questo ragionamento
mi servirò di un altro mito che mi che
mi è molto utile è il mito di narciso il
bellissimo figlio di lirio per la ninfa
marica lo ricorderete tutti si innamora
così tanto della sua bella immagine
riflessa nell'acqua che si dimentica di
mangiare e di bere e alla fine muore
anzi quindi possiamo dire che in pratica
si dimentica completamente di avere di
avere un corpo
secondo me l'immagine di di narciso è
proprio il mito di narciso proprio
quello che potrebbe
finire per descrivere al meglio la
situazione in cui ci troviamo oggi
rispetto al tema della bellezza
in effetti ci possiamo fare questa
domanda come cambia la bellezza in un
ambiente che è sempre meno naturale e
sempre più digitale pensateci un attimo
se la bellezza è stata una forza
naturale che c'è stato come utile
criterio inconscio per sopravvivere in
un ambiente che c era ostile ora che
grazie alla tecnica abbiamo trasformato
e l'ambiente completamente a nostra
immagine e somiglianza
l'esistenza del bello ha ancora senso
nella
nell'universo nel mondo digitale in cui
in cui viviamo
la nostra esperienza è tutta trasposta
in una pura fantasmagoria immaginaria
fatto tutto d'immagine se si escludono i
piccoli device sulle quali queste
immagini
girano la nostra esperienza esistenziale
è una strana declinazione di qualcuno
che interagisce con uno schermo sia per
lavorare che per
trovare un partner o per occupare il
cosiddetto tempo libero
tanto per darvi un dato che vi fa capire
la dimensione della della trasformazione
a cui siamo andati incontro
pensate a questo nel medioevo mediamente
un europeo
nella sua vita nelle sua intera vita si
imbatteva in una quarantina di immagini
artificiali oggi nel 2022 fu un
adolescente europeo si imbatte in
400 mila immagini al giorno e
quindi la
per fare anche per chiudere con una
analisi di un elemento molto
comune che un po ci ricorda narciso è
questo cioè il self i am
pensate ai sensi il self in se stessi
non sono niente di straordinario non
esistono i ritratti autoritratti
esistono da centinaio di anni nella
storia
della pittura ma in verità il self ha
degli aspetti di novità assolutamente
peculiari beh innanzitutto è
probabilmente il più il genere visuale
più diffuso di sempre con più praticanti
di sempre è un fenomeno senza precedenti
nella storia da questo da questo punto
di vista e poi ha una funzione
immediatamente comunicativa
non importa assolutamente
quello che c'è nel selfin è più
importante che il sel si dica io sono
qui ora sono qui ora è inoltre la
condivisione su degli spazi social di
questi selphy e delle proprie narrazioni
identitarie attraverso di essi crea
delle straordinarie delle norme comunità
virtuale kim kardashian kim kardashian a
289 milioni di amici sui social che li
mettono laiche che
da qui a cui lei piace
289 milioni di amici che non credo abbia
mai invitato alla sua festa di
compleanno e quindi allora possiamo
chiederci ci serve ancora la bellezza in
questo ambiente che abbiamo creato noi e
che abitiamo noi è che è a nostra
immagine e somiglianza possiamo farne a
meno dato che ha esaurito il suo compito
biologico non ci resta forse che fare
come narciso e quindi
immergersi in un mondo di beata
contemplazione nel quale
fondamentalmente la bellezza con le sue
contraddizioni non ha più non ha più
cittadinanza a
narciso aveva una possibilità di
salvarsi e questa possibilità era
rappresentante se vi ricordate dalla
ninfa ecco anni fa eco lo chiamava e lo
amava di carne ed ossa per com'era
ecco se noi vogliamo continuare un po
questa storia che si chiama umanità
forse dovremmo di tanto in tanto di
svolgere distogliere lo sguardo da noi
stessi e guardare quanto sono belli gli
altri grazie
[Applauso]